la direction de l'agriculture et de la
forêt
abritant aujourd'hui la direction de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture et de la
forêt ce bâtiment est l'oeuvre d'un
éminent disciple de le corbusier
l'architecte jean bossu construit de
1967 à 1970 dans le parc de la
providence à saint-denis
il fait partie d'un ensemble
administrative de trois bâtiments ne
dépassant pas deux niveaux ces édifices
longiline se fondent harmonieusement
dans la pente douce du terrain le
bâtiment principal en forme de ciseaux
se compose de deux ailes deux hauteurs
différentes la plus haute comporte un
étage pour éviter la monotonie
l'architecte a savamment varier le
traitement de la trame constructive de 4
m rythmant la façade
plusieurs détails architecturaux
reprennent des motifs chers à le
corbusier
parmi eux le grand auvent marquant
l'entrée du bâtiment
un vaste projet de réhabilitation
concernant principalement l'intérieur du
bâtiment a été confiée en 2010 à
l'architecte olivier brabant
son intervention a notamment consisté à
remettre en selle cette structure en
redessinant les espaces de travail mais
aussi les parties communes
hall d'accueil végétalisée couloirs
élargis ou encore éclairage naturel
optimisé à l'issue de deux années de
travaux cet aménagement donne nouvelle
vie à ce bâtiment emblématique de
l'oeuvre de jean bossu à la réunion